Bắt biệt, nhà trắng ngày bắt mua thường bà thường phổng ý đoàn trọng cho biết
Washington có thể kết thúc chính sĩ của Ivan trọng 2 đi ba tần tới
Đồng thường nhà định đồng thái này có thể có phần hãi ạy sáng lợt
Thong khiến rồi tân tổng trọng cũng nhận mạnh Mỹ không cần đàn đêm một thỏa thuật
chính thức với tưu ra này chính sĩ chính sĩnh sĩnh sĩnh sĩnh sĩnh sĩnh sĩnh sĩnh sàng
Ivan xuống tổng thần thần phát nước phát triển vụ phía nhận
Nguyên đồng nhà trắng mua tàn chính sĩnh sĩnh sĩnh sĩnh sĩnh sĩnh sĩnh
Đồng thơ chương sẵn tình hình tảy ra găng con nhấn thầy đổi giết định
Ông cũng cho biết Mỹ sẽ không khăn thịp chức tiếp vào việc bảo đảm ảnh hành hài tới biển
Thong muốn cho rằng các khu xa liên quan cần tự bảo vệ lợi ý của mình
Cung ngày tổng thống Ivan mà xuống o vô và giết xin khảy định
Tây ra không có đủ cuối tâm chấm giữ xuống đột sống nhấn mạnh
Con có các bảo đầm để trắng tài sĩnh khẳng thần thần